the three main types of methodology for
valuation or travel costs contingent
valuation and choice experiments so
hopefully by the end of the day you'll
have a pretty good idea about how you
might undertake one of these surveys so
it's kind of going to be very practical
hands-on about how you might undertake
these so the first one is travel costs
so travel costs is I revealed preference
technique and so what you're doing is
trying to work out the value of usually
a recreation site and it's revealed by
observing actual behavior so one of the
nice things about travel cost method is
its base and people's actual real
behavior so people are traveling to
Grand Canyon's are traveling to yield
forest whatever natural resource that
you're looking at so nice thing compared
to this compared to the stated
preference techniques it's real behavior
stated preference techniques we ask
people hypothetical questions about how
we evaluate which can be an issue it
came back to nineteen forty seven when a
guy called hardl hotelling he was a
national park warden and his boss asked
them what why should i give you more
money for investing in his naturals park
and he had to try and justify it so
wrote a letter to his boss and say well
people are traveling all around America
all around the world to come to this
site I can't remember what site it was
but if they're willing to spend that
money coming here surely that has
something to do with demonstrating that
it must be important to them the kind of
state of the art and travel cost is
what's called the random utility travel
costs and I'll see a little bit more
about random utility theory when they
talk about choice experiments but what
basic means is that you have a choice
about which site you go to so if you're
thinking about forests may be around
deal there's five different forests
within an hour's drive so you as someone
who's going to go walking in the forest
you choose which forest you prefer so
your choice will depend on the
attributes of that forest you have a
choice about which site you go to see if
you're thinking about for
is maybe around Yale there's five
different forests within an hour's drive
so you as someone who's going to go
walking in the forest you choose which
forest you prefer so your choice will
depend on the attributes of that forest
so if you're going mountain biking it
might be different forest with my own
bike trails where others don't have if
you're going walking it might be one
switch I've got more nature there to
look at or and the forest will be
different distances to you so what the
random utility model does is look at the
suite of alternatives and substitute
sites looks at the attributes all those
sites and tries and work site why do you
travel to that particular site what's
what's the benefits what's the
environmental quality of that site to
meet you choose to go there so what
you're analyzing is people's choice of
forest to try and then I certain the
value of that forest in different
components of it